tanzania has announced new measures to
control the spread of the coronavirus it
is a
major departure from the approach taken
by former president
john magufuli who played down the
pandemic before his death
earlier in the year the new leader samia
hassan
has been in office for a month she's
been in neighboring kenya on a visit
aimed at improving trade relations
observers say that hassan is gradually
paving the way toward more democracy in
tanzania
so how do the opposition and ordinary
citizens assess the start of her
leadership
well dw's charles combe reports now from
dar es salaam
[Music]
expectations were high when samia solo
hassan took over
as tanzania's president following the
death of joni magufuli
his rule was marked by controversy and
division
hassan has started a process of change
that
many see as a fresh start for the
country
she has lifted a media ban allowed
public debate
formed a curvy 19 task force and is
seeking to end years of tension
between opposition and government
in the interest of protecting democracy
i intend to meet with all political
party leaders
to discuss how they can best conduct
their political activities for the
benefit of our country
this marks a big shift from her
predecessor
critics say magufuli used the law to
repress political decent
in tanzania opposition politicians
are now more optimistic the president
samia sulu hassan has shown leadership
in in various issues and as an
opposition
leader we have seen her extending that
olive branch and we
think we are going to go to the
discussion table and have a good
discussion about the future of our
country
hassan's style of leadership is also
different
less the bulldozer as magufulo is known
she's more diplomatic analysts say
that could be good not just domestically
intention to meet with opposition
leaders is a good thing that will
strengthen democracy international
because men are so tanzania as a country
that limits people's freedom of
expression
and limits opposition parties from
performing their activities
rights activists are also happy for her
son
to enact change we were not safe in the
even political
parties leaders and other ngos
leaders were not actually safe under
under the the previous leadership
we think that mama samir sulu hassan has
started well
tanzanian citizens are keen to see what
hassan's leadership
brings a she should default her ability
and what the constitution says the
constitution is the mother law
and if she follows it she will be
touching us directly
as used to go to her and tell her our
challenges
because tanzanians want to progress
that's the thing so there's that
opportunity to talk to a mother who's
willing to listen
to the development which if it helps the
youth it can help the country grow
hassan has already touched on key issues
affecting tanzania like democracy
and development rising hopes for change
implementing these changes may yet
proved to be a challenge
despite a different approach she's from
the same party as magufuli
and she will still need his backing
and we are joined now by charles combe
who is joining us from dar es salaam he
sent us that report
charles uh thank you for joining us tell
us i mean the new tanzanian president
hassan is in nairobi at the moment to
join the kenyan president in tackling
the coronavirus
how big of a departure from her of her
policies
are from her predecessor who downplayed
the virus
at some point he even said that it had
been defeated by prayer
well it is a big uh move
that uh higher excellency seniors and
has done
contrary to what was done by happiness
as you all know that uh tanzania stopped
publishing coordinating cases of death
since april last year and later one
month later the president
elect president announced that tanzania
was covenanting free and that gold and
traditional remedies has made that
achievement so uh what uh salinas
hassan is doing now is uh has been
welcomed by many
and many people are seeing this uh as a
seriousness uh as her government is
serious about
tackling this infection and also it will
also
reduce the people that were there before
between tanzania and kenya as
okay charles tell us um what other than
the coronavirus pandemic
what are some of the most urgent
challenges right now in the country
well uh among the challenges uh
currently is the issue of democracy
as uh during the late german fully
we saw that there were some of the laws
that
criminalized democratic processes in
tanzania
and also the issue of replacing
opposition politicians so what is now
she's now going to face is to make sure
that she
removes all the repressive laws that can
be planning place
and uh to make sure that uh
to to put in place some of the new laws
that abide to the issue of democracy
charles combe joining us from dar es
salaam thank you so much
you